y
[Música]
el crudo aún no ha sido limpiado es muy
muy denso aún se puede ver como mancha
la piel como mancha en las manos
estas manchas de petróleo se encuentran
en la selva amazónica de la provincia de
orellana en ecuador aparecieron después
de que una tubería ubicada más al
occidente del país se rompiera el pasado
28 de enero según s&p que es la empresa
privada ecuatoriana que gestiona este
oleoducto este resultó dañado por la
caída de rocas provocadas por la erosión
y las fuertes lluvias se cree que se han
derramado más de un millón de litros de
petróleo
luís javier solís es un abogado de la
provincia de orellana que cree que esta
situación es un desastre tanto para los
habitantes como para el medio ambiente
en el río volga y el río napo por donde
ha recorrido el derrame de petróleo que
atraviesa áreas protegidas que son de
cuidado especial para el ecuador que ha
habido una gran afectación a todos los
estés y la habitación por lo menos está
en un gran modelo de 160 kilómetros
tiene un recorrido desde el lugar del
derrame hasta la frontera y por perú y
la afectación a los pueblos indígenas a
las orillas de estos ríos también es muy
grave espíritu
crea tristeza de que no suceda siempre
esto
y donde nosotros nos abastecemos con el
líquido vital las comunas indígenas
viven del frío por lo que estamos
hablando de cerca de 27 mil pobladores
de la nacionalidad kichwa ellos beben el
agua de papelillos se bañan en los ríos
se consumen los alimentos que hay en
estos ríos y todos estos elementos han
sido dañados
en ecuador hay dos oleoductos que
transportan petróleo desde la amazonía
hasta la costa del pacífico tras la fuga
instalo cubetas de retención y comenzó a
limpiar la zona y a reparar la tubería
acp alega que el accidente no baila
previsible lo que no satisface a nuestro
observador ya que en las últimas dos
décadas se habían producido otras fugas
de petróleo en esa misma zona
hemos manifestado en diferentes momentos
que internamente ocurrió el 28 de enero
era un adarme previsible y además que
podría haberse evitado hubieron varias
abiertas científicas y también de las
organizaciones que advertíamos que no
pueden seguirse haciendo un trazado del
oleoducto a los márgenes de fríos y en
especular están expuestos a situaciones
de desprendimiento de tierra y de caída
de rocas y cerca de sectores volcánicos
estas advertencias han sido desatendidas
por parte del estado ecuatoriano y por
parte de las empresas privadas lo que ha
ocasionado este clavo derrame
tomaron agua
tal vez cocinaron y necesitaron agua tal
vez se bañaron
el agua que sale de este grifo está
contaminada y es peligrosa este vídeo
fue grabado en una reserva indígena de
canadá en donde no en acceso al agua
potable algo común también en otras
zonas del país algunas comunidades
indígenas se enfrentan a este problema
desde hace décadas el agua puede estar
contaminada con metales pesados y otras
bacterias que pueden causar graves
problemas de salud todo ello debido a
las malas infraestructuras y a la falta
de regulación
primer mac ayer ha compartido a través
de tick tock varios videos en donde
evidencia la contaminación del agua
y me mudé a la propiedad donde vivo hace
un año y medio o dos años recuerdo que
fui a ver a mi compañero de piso y le
dije el agua no huele muy bien y tampoco
sabe muy bien recuerdo haber tomado una
ducha y que el agua salió negra aquí se
aconseja hervir el agua desde 2008
el gobierno canadiense emitió
advertencias para las comunidades en las
que el agua no es potable así que a
veces la gente hierve el agua antes de
usarla pero en otros lugares no es en
absoluto apta para el consumo los
dirigentes actuales han conseguido
solucionar 130 problemas de agua potable
desde el 2015 pero miles de personas que
viven en 29 comunidades indígenas siguen
adaptándose a vivir sin agua potable
para asegurarnos de que podemos
ducharnos lavar los platos hacer todas
esas cosas que la gente normal puede
hacer tenemos que poner cloro en nuestro
sistema de filtración
también
which
y tenemos la suerte de tener aquí agua
que no es demasiado cara y que podemos
comprar y también tenemos el privilegio
de contar con varios puestos en los que
podemos tener botellones de agua hay
personas que tienen sed y no tienen
acceso al agua es realmente aterrador
poniendo está en esa situación
es aterrador creo que lo que realmente
se ha visto afectado es la salud mental
de muchas personas antes de la
colonización distribuimos nuestros
recursos de forma equitativa entre
nuestros pueblos
llegó la colonización y de repente
nuestros recursos de agua dulce nuestros
bosques
todo eso fue contaminado y destruir
estos dos por esta semana en los
observadores de france 24 queremos
agradecer a nuestros observadores por
sus historias recuerden que si ustedes
quieren comunicarse con la producción
del programa lo pueden hacer a los datos
de contacto que aparecen en sus
pantallas esperamos sus historias sus
vídeos y también sus fotografías
nosotros nos vemos la próxima semana
hasta entonces